I'm on the x-axis okay so I'm just
taking the X boundaries is that okay so
we're going not 200 now what I'm after
here now is I'm going to go ahead and
write PI Y squared DX right I know some
people have mentioned this when we first
learnt it I know some people like to put
that pie out the front I am gonna do
that in a second but I like keeping this
you because what is this what does this
represent what is it where did these
pieces come yeah it's tiny cylinders
right
tiny tiny cylinders PI R squared H yes
do you remember that okay so now I'll
put that PI out the front it's still
from naught to PI on 4 and of course Y
squared in this case is twice greatest
it's expert okay that's much happier
looking right so now I can integrate
this is PI by telex from naught to PI
landfall and now I'm just going to
evaluate I'm getting 10 a pound 4 which
is 1 minus 10 of 0 which is 0 okay
that's it better that's not the answer
by the way that is not it it's a volume
right so I'm going to say by the way I
mentioned this before derivatives and
integrals strictly speaking not units
they don't have units on them so pi is
this number I'm going to conclude
therefore the volume is you won't be
like penalize or anything if all you do
is tack on units cubed there because we
get it you're lining it's a volume
that's the basic ID but I like to do it
correctly so the volume is something
separate and I use the integral to get
that right once we go through our
question who's a lot easier let's move
on I in definite definite sorry we're
gonna do chain rule and identity and
you'll see they they float together
quite neatly okay uh here we go the
integral of cos 2x okay now again just
like I did would be indefinite
integrals I'm going to write this in
such a way to take advantage of the fact
that I know my derivatives really well
what derivatives would have led to
something like this I would have
expected a two out the front would not
right so if I had had a 2 cos 2x you're
like oh is the inside of that so of
course I can't just point in there too
because I want to I need to compensate
and now that I see this 1/2 remains
there 2 cos 2 X simply came from side to
it your constant okay and of course
again you can check it so easy to check
used to your derivative to check I
encourage you to do that because the
more you practice I know it sounds weird
but the more you practice switching back
and forth the better you get at
distinguishing between the two and
knowing when to do one in well when
you're doing chain rule here right yeah
good you seen the panel I can say oh
that's just the inside function right so
therefore that that number will just
about the front just like I do with
polynomials okay now when you have a
look at this one
students get twisted around when they
look at these because it just looks
funny you wouldn't believe it not people
we try and do an expansion here you
can't do it that way by the way I just
just don't know why you would okay I'm
going to treat this as these are chain
really operation here so I want to write
this in such a way to make the
derivative more obvious okay so what's
the derivative of the inside function
here it's just a negative one right so I
was kind of expecting that there will be
a negative one there right so since
there's a negative and it may want to be
a negative out the front okay so now
that I have that menu there what's gonna
happen to this guy
negative Clause is gonna turn into now
just watch out right it's kind of funny
cuz here there's like a double double
double triple quadruple negative or
whatever it is okay because cars right
came from sign
came from science so therefore if I were
a sign of pine for [ __ ] just check this
for a second does it work out does it
send us back where I came from
think about it so here you have to be
carefully refer back to your original
indefinite integrals right no regular
sign regular sign turns into client but
this is not regular sign this is sign
with chain rule involved right so this
might have sign where does it come from
it comes from the inside function it
doesn't come from this guy does that
make sense and I can just verify this
right if I differentiate this back a
negative sign we climb out the front for
chain rule to cancel that and you end up
here like this I would just tell you to
cross okay so if I wanted to write if I
wanted to I could do this another way so
I could say hey hey hold on a second
cause of X is equal to cos of minus X
because cosine is an even function it's
reflected across the y-axis so in fact
this is also equal to this okay now what
happens when I write the next line when
I'm doing the reverse chain will be this
still chain will happening it just that
the derivative is 1 right so this is
going to be sine of X minus PI on the
floor because I have a new inside
function plus my constant is this right
I cannot be careful be careful we can
but it's not because I can take the
minus out it's because side is what kind
of function
it's odd right so f of X is minus F of
minus X if because of the symmetry that
I can take advantage of that